this video is sponsored by curiosity
stream
the first three episodes of the wire go
into painstaking detail unraveling the
steps and process leading up to the
baltimore police department making a
drug bust but when they finally make the
bust they find someone beat them to it
we're that man this is how we're
introduced to omar little the most
iconic character on one of the greatest
shows of all time omar is a step ahead
he's the classic western stick up man
recast in urban baltimore i ain't
tossing nothing
bow tie robbing drug dealers outsmarting
the police he might be playing the game
but even when he cooperates with the law
or gangs it's clear he's doing so on his
terms i believe anything you say that's
up to y'all really omar lives by a code
i mean there are some rules here right
rules yeah
no mistakes no bystanders
no taxpayers getting caught up in the
mix and he sets the parameters of that
code and look i never put my gun on
those citizens omar is a rogue agent a
true rebel outlaw
for such an iconic memorable character
he received a relatively small amount of
screen time relative to some of the
other major characters that omar left
such an outsized impact was a testament
to several things the character was a
bit of flair for the theatrical and
mythical in a show that was overall
pretty dedicated to understatedness omar
created his own mythos on the streets
mars is the god of war right
planet too
well i know it's a planet but the clue
is greek god of
war aries
aerys fitz
thanks
it's all good
see back in middle school and all that's
a lot of myths
stuff was deep
truly but that mythos extended into the
show itself you don't need to open this
door man for a huff and puff
[Music]
hey yo lesson here babe
you coming the king
you best not miss
but more importantly was omar's position
within the broader themes of the show in
my past series of videos on the wire i
talked about how the wires attention to
detail realism and accuracy make it
great how the unique setting each season
brings to the story illustrates
baltimore as a character and how small
moments with characters are used to
reveal the show's broader themes and how
all these things work together to
illustrate the systems and institutions
in baltimore and the difficulty of
reforming them but while those themes
are fascinating to discuss and that
thesis is responsible for a lot of the
show's depth and lasting impact those
things are only slowly revealed over
time as you watch the show to be a more
successful tv show the wire had to grab
audiences attention and make you care
about its characters long before it had
time to really unravel the details of
its more complex themes nah darling i'm
cool
the wire is one of the first shows i
remember watching that made me
sympathetic for two characters that were
in direct conflict with each other jimmy
mcnulty is perhaps the closest thing the
show has to an obvious protagonist and
as a viewer i was drawn to root for him
in his goal of doing better police work
deangelo barksdale on the other hand is
a drug dealer he's one of the people
mcnulty is out to lock up but somehow i
found myself also wanting to root for
deangelo how can you want two characters
to achieve their goals when those goals
have competing outcomes a show
developing sympathy for characters that
are in opposition is more common in tv
now but at the time the wire hit screens
it was a much more novel idea for
television there are several ways you
can make characters that are at odds
sympathetic but i think there's a very
specific reason why we're drawn to root
for so many of the characters in the
wire
we usually root for rebels in stories
narratively we love an underdog there
are few stories made about the existing
forces of power simply defending and
maintaining their power it's not a
compelling narrative for viewers we want
to see the little guy take down the big
bad guys around him the wire is full of
rebels characters that in their own way
are pushing back against an established
system and set of institutions that are
much stronger and more powerful than
they are in season one mcnulty is a
rebel within the police force he often
disregards the bureaucratic authority
above him fighting to accomplish what he
calls good police work wallace is also a
rebel fighting against the systemic
influences that are pushing him deeper
into gang activity i just i just don't
want to play i just don't want to play
no more all right so is deangelo
although he's deeper into that system
yeah but the game ain't gotta be played
like that yo and bubbles though he
relies on the illegal drug trade to
maintain his drug use works as an
informant against that very drug trade
in season one the characters our
sympathies lie with and the characters
we want to root for are the ones that
are pushing back against their own
institutions many of these characters
aren't admirable people and none of them
are perfect jimmy is an openly pretty
terrible person d'angelo is even a
murderer but i think we're willing to
overlook those things and sympathize
with them because these characters
recognize that something is wrong with
the world around them and they want to
see change you gotta let me live like i
need to live
you tell avon
stringer and on it
all of them
to let me be
instead of just blindly following the
path that's set out for them by the
system the characters that we dislike in
the show tend to be the ones that align
themselves with the system that don't
see a problem and don't do anything to
seek change
there are many characters that viewers
sympathies shift for over the course of
the show's five seasons in the first
season i didn't really find myself
sympathizing with string or bell but i
was somewhat by season three what
changed well from season one to three
stringer moves from being someone who
perpetuates the institution he's in the
drug trade to someone who wants to
reform how that institution is run
officer perez is one of the most
despisable characters in season one but
by season four he's someone i'm rooting
for and want to succeed but prez isn't
the same character in season one and
four over time he changes from someone
who simply perpetuates and benefits from
the system he's in to one who sees the
problems with the system he's in and
actively works to improve it the same
goes for bodhi who i hate in season one
for murdering wallace but by season four
bodie is ready to push back against the
system he's a part of the system that
pushed him to murder wallace and he
ultimately loses his life because of it
and when he does it doesn't feel like
cathartic revenge for wallace it feels
genuinely sad
some characters reflect the opposite of
this carcadi starting out is a
rebellious force in politics pushing for
change in the system and he's a fairly
likable and sympathetic character but
once he becomes mayor he loses some of
that rebellious spark and we begin to
lose our sympathy
these rebellious characters are the
lifeblood of the wire bonnie colvin
fights against the very laws he's
upholding and then against the way
education is done lester freeman in his
own way pushes back against the
aggressive violent manipulative
tendencies of the police force with his
quiet and calculating approach to police
work
but the most rebel of all the rebels is
omar little
we can root for characters that are in
conflict in the wire because the true
conflict of the show is not really about
police officers versus drug dealers it's
about individuals versus the
institutions they reside in look man i
do what i can do to help y'all
but the game is out there
and it's either play or get played
instead of casting one side as the
established power and the other side as
the rebels the wirecast institutions
themselves as the established powers and
the rebels as anyone who is willing to
push back against the corrupt elements
of their institution the wire doesn't
paint individuals as the enemy but
institutional forces that incentivize
the bad behavior individuals choose to
participate in this perspective doesn't
eliminate the personal responsibility
and agency of individuals but it does
shift the way we view those things if
the system is the true villain of the
show omar holds a unique position
relative to that villain
every other rebel in the show is a part
of some aspect of the interlocking
series of systems and institutions in
baltimore the drug dealers and dock
workers align with organized crime the
police officers with the corrupt police
department karketi ultimately with a
corrupt city government but omar is the
one character that is clearly his own
man he doesn't play by the rules handed
to him by a system but strictly by his
own moral code he even flaunts the rules
of the game holding himself to an even
higher moral standard he repeatedly
allows people to live when they fully
expect to be killed yeah i want to
report a shooting overhead the new motel
on north avenue even though killing them
would be seen as collateral damage
within the game omar stays away from
deadly violence unless he sees it as
justified retribution when one of his
crew is accidentally killed in a
firefight and bunk confronts him about
it he tries to appeal to the death as
just the cost of doing business within
the game she passed that y'all gonna
have to call this one of them um
because of doing business things y'all
police be talking about all the time
you feel me
no taxpayers shoot the way y'all looking
on things ain't no victim to even speak
on using the unfeeling attitude with
which the drug and police institutions
treat the death but bunk challenges that
position we had us a community
nobody no victim who didn't matter and
omar even though it goes against the
advice of his trusted confidant he
walking you with guilt boy honors his
conscience over the rules of the game i
still feel like i owe something butch
while his day-to-day might come from
playing the game most of his actions
that we see in the show are motivated by
the pursuit of justice when people he
loved or cared about are killed or put
in danger see all i know
is whoever did him that way it gets got
when he eventually realizes that his
playing the game puts people around him
in danger he exits the game only drawn
back in because of a wrong committed
against someone else that he loved
omar has a terrifying mythos on the
streets venice man such as myself does
not believe in bad blood with a man such
as yourself he's a character whose name
carries weight so you can rob me now
i need to remind you who i am and his
character represents an important
thematic element at the core of the show
but the final ingredient that made the
character so lasting was the actor
behind the role the brilliance of
michael k williams performance was to
play a character that fully embodied the
myth oman come back tomorrow
and the next day
and the next day
and i will put a bullet in all y'all
behind what happened right now you heard
making it believable that people ran at
the mere mention of his name all while
bringing a genuine humanity to that role
the writers of the show often demanded a
lot of their actors leaving important
motivation out of exposition left to be
revealed on the faces of the cast when
omar decides to follow his conscience
instead of accepting the rules of the
game it's the visible guilt and turmoil
in william's performance that makes the
characters actions feel motivated and
genuine
he brought a character that could have
been cartoonish to life with a rich
complexity
it was a careful balancing act in a
performance that in many ways reflected
the careful balancing act of the show as
a whole
the wire paints a world where we don't
judge a character by what side they're
on or what institution they're a part of
or what they've done in the past
and the wire we judge a character by the
spirit and attitude with which they face
the world around them
omar little like everyone else on the
show was not perfect but in the face of
a complex world of corrupt
interconnected institutions he may have
been the only character who lived free
from the bonds of those
institutions if you would put all of
omar scenes from the show together you
would have over a feature-length film's
worth of material i looked through all
of that in preparation for this video
and there was a lot of cool stuff in
there that i just didn't have time to
include in this video so i've made a
companion video that examines what
omar's code is specifically and how that
evolves over the course of the show and
you can watch that video on nebula
nebula is a streaming platform created
by myself and a bunch of other great
creators so that we have a place to post
our videos that's owned by us you can
watch all my content on there ad free
and before it's on youtube alongside the
content of a ton of other great creators
like patrick williams jacob geller like
stories of old and a lot of others and
the best way to get nebula is to get
curiosity stream when you use my link in
the description below you can get an
entire year of both curiosity stream and
nebula for less than fifteen dollars
that's 26 percent off the normal price
curiosity stream is one of the best
places online to watch documentaries
they recently added one of my favorite
documentaries of all time art and craft
it's about a notorious art forger it's a
really interesting look into that world
but it's also just a fascinating
character study of a very unique person
it does look like a million dollars
because that because actually that's
worth about i mean
maybe not quite watch it right now
alongside the thousands of other great
titles on curiositystream and my omar's
code video alongside all the other great
content on nebula when you subscribe
using the link below not only do you get
access to a bunch of great content but
you directly support my content and a
bunch of other creators like myself sign
up today using the link on the screen
the wire is my favorite tv show of all
time and if you haven't seen my other
videos on the wire i definitely
recommend you give those a watch thanks
so much for watching and special thank
you to my patrons for their support
[Music]
you